部活でスコーンを作ったの
狂っちょっと知っていっていうわけでみなさん
ゲームと受けられてますでしょうか彩未のゲームのがあるんですけども最近のゲームは
もっぱら
サバイバルゲームだと思うんですよこういう bj もや高度ばいろいろあると思うん
ですけどもサバイバルゲームそこをどうなのかというとなんかこのシムとかに飯700
人ぐらいと集まってそこで最後まで生き残った人が重傷3でとだからみんな
はでその生き残るために人を殺めたり時には良いの中に身を隠れたり台がに向かって
爆弾を投げたりとこう
とんでもない行動するんですけどもっとゲームの中でめちゃくちゃ強いアイテムがある
んですよ
それがこちらを見ながら磯で戦うサバイバル感ある入れ物でやっ
こんなにオサレなんだあ普通にいい感じ
開けましょうんん
どうなってんだからあの変わってん
草やギリースーツっていうものがあるんですよギリースーツとは主に職業柄身を隠す
必要がある場合が多いでしょう激暑やハンガーが大和パック様においてみを
カモフラージュするために移籍をするものでございます
要するにゲーム内だってもう誰かに突然打たれたりしちゃの服着てれば冷静からすぐ
撃たれたりするんでおおいですねあの草ナポリ港
して草むらにか5 colors して隠れるという作戦がとっても強いですときてみ
ましょう
もうなるほどなるほどこういうこういうこういうことね
すげーもんは
はいないんだけどちょっと自分だとよくわかんないんですけど結構かくれるそんな気が
しますよねゲーム中田と本当に強いんですよ
記事数釣れるけど今日はちょっと家の近くにね家の近くちょっと大きさが入ってる
ところがあるんですよでゲームんだかだと全然ばれないんですけどちょっと現実世界に
ギリースーツで本当に隠れるかどうか僕ちょっとわかんないんで今日は家の近くの
草むらに僕が張って隠れ
てリリース好きで本当にカモフラージュしてバレないかどうかちょっと日て行きたいと
思いますでは以下かよちゃんないん
じゃあちょっとで出会う二人でてあの
一人ずつ4分で
帰って来てくださいジャンここでいつかもおっ
ンスって
ええええええ
頑張ってびっくりしたああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
はいて受けて早速完全にイギリスずに着替えました中の服はバレないように黒にしたの
でカモフラージュ的には完璧だと思いますでは現場へ向かいます
最低で外に行きましたここらへんにちょっと植物があるのでここらへんに隠れてみよう
と思いません
[音楽]
ムズいん
バスを変更します今5家の近くにいるんですけどもここらへんがきっと道ができないか
と思いましてここらへんに隠れてみようと思います
多分
どうでしたかなんか掃除機自分だと隠れてるかどうかよくわかんないんですよそれで
もうすぐ一立家に帰ってくるんでいいに入って絶対ここを通るんですよ
その通る過程でそこらへんの植物にかぼぶらーずした僕がバレるかバレないか
[拍手]
ん
[音楽]
わー熱いとって
[拍手]
くれません
すごい
すごいチョコれます
ん
me
ear fun ん
ああああああああ tjar
[音楽]
最強や
they 件
醸造指定
ています
me
ん
始めさーん
9号3ランで1点を奪った
やばいよ
[音楽]
ブーバーシアー
me
dea
car
me あった
間違いですね
さーわー